-Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]
You guys, we are so excited
to be back.
My heart is racing so fast,
I feel like I took pills
from a Russian figure skater.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
I really do. Ah!
That's right,
the Beijing Olympics
are officially over,
but there's still a moment
that everyone's talking about.
During a race on Saturday,
in especially cold temperatures,
a skier from Finland suffered
a -- well, just listen.
-A cross-country skier
from Finland
experienced frozen penis
while competing.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
-What? What?
What?!
[ Rimshot ]
-He used it to his advantage,
though.
For two of the turns,
he didn't even use a ski pole.
-Really?!
-Yeah, it's very
interesting to watch.
[ Laughter ]
-Thrrr!
-People could tell
[ Laughter ]
something was wrong when he was
doing a handstand under the hand
dryers in the men's room.
Oh, my --
Thank God he's an Olympian
because I wouldn't have
the hand strength.
[ Laughter ]
I feel for the guy, though.
He's trained for years
and now that's what comes up
when you Google him.
You know what I'm saying?
-Aw.
[ Laughter ]
He went back to the locker room,
took off his uniform,
and heard --
[ Glass breaking ]
"Alright, here we go.
[ Laughter, ohs, and applause ]
-Oh!
-Just clean that up. Oh!"
That's right,
the Beijing Olympics are over
and the 2026 Games are in Italy.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah.
That'll be fun.
That'll probably be fun.
When you win a gold there,
they just kind of palm the medal
during a handshake.
They go, "Here, this is for you.
[ Laughter ]
A little something. Come here,
a little something for you."
[ Laughter ]
[ Mumbling ]
Well, guys, the big story
right now is
that the U.S. is all
but certain Russia
is going to invade Ukraine.
[ Boos ]
As we speak, Putin is flipping
a coin like --
[ As Putin ]
Heads, I invade.
Tails, I invade shirtless.
[ Laughter ]
Putin's about as undecided
as when a server asks
if you want a side salad
or fries. You go --
[ Laughter ]
"I think we know
what I'm going to get."
[ Laughter ]
To avoid war,
French President Emmanuel Macron
is trying to arrange a sitdown
with Biden and Putin.
Yep, leave it to France
to settle a problem
with a three-way.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
Ukrainian troops have been
standing out there for months,
waiting for the invasion.
Soldiers are like --
[ Slavic accent ]
We're freezing out here.
And then,
the skier from Finland is like,
"You don't know what freezing...
[ Laughter and applause ]
...is.
Let's just --
Let's just be honest.
You have no idea."
Meanwhile, in other news,
former President Trump
just launched his new social
media app, Truth Social,
[ Booing ]
and it crashed shortly
after launching.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I mean, I think it crashed.
I'm not sure. I read it
on the Truth Social app.
[ Laughter ]
Some business news --
I saw that Family Dollar had
to shut down hundreds of stores
due to a rat infestation
at one of its warehouses.
It's bad.
The rats have already caused
dollars in damages.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, a man in Florida
was arrested for a DUI
and is making headlines
for telling officers
that he was high and happy
when they pulled him over.
[ Laughter ]
And this is real.
Can we see a photo of him?
[ Laughter ]
He looks like a guy who lives
on the border
between Russia and Ukraine.
[ Laughter ]
Can we see him again?
Yeah. They found out
the man's identity.
He's the Olympic skier
from Finland.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Really?
-That's him, yeah.